hello everyone and welcome back to the
London chest classic the Grantchester
finals its Lebanon vs. Magnus Crossin
and this is the first game of the rapid
so in the classical time section Magnus
Carlsen was able to win a game so he's
up six points in the match and now they
will be playing two rapid games and for
blitz games they decide who will take
third place in the grand chester so it's
really an exciting game but before we
check that out
we do have some photos from this event
there was also a special guest here we
have Woody Harrelson is making the first
move for Magnus Carlsen it's not from
this game it's from the second rapid
game but I thought I'd share it
nevertheless and if we remember during
last year's World Chess Championship
match woody made a different moved in
Caruana wanted he thought it would be
very funny so maybe maybe he did the
same thing here as a Magnus did not want
to play d4 and also here you can see
he's giving xi a nice swing and Magnus
retracted the move so I don't know maybe
maybe he was just trolling Magnus to see
if it would be funny again but yeah now
I just wanted to share that now let's
check out the game and also I do have a
very special favor to ask of you
but I cannot mention it you you will
have to read about it in the description
below so that's that and also today is
Hikaru Nakamura's birthday so if you
happen to run into him in a bar or a
library you know make sure to wish him
all the best so that being said 11 with
the white pieces opens with Knight to f3
we have d5 by Magnus we have C 4 by 11
d4 advancing the point even further
sorry about that
and now b4 just expecting C 5 so we have
C 5 by Magnus and the g3 preparing to
fin get to the light square bishop so
here 11 wants to just give up the b4 in
maybe even the a3 pawn so sort of a sort
of a reversed Benko idea C character son
before and now a3 Magnus decides he
wants to give up the pawn this way we
have b3 and now d3 by 11 we have Knight
to c6 and a knight beat the
- and this position has been reached
before for example in the 2018 Tata
Steel tournament
Bhaskar inaudib and had it against
vishwanathan anand the dead game ended
in a draw and in the game
'if i was played by Anand but here we
have a five Bell by Magnus and it is as
of move as eight that we have a
completely new game on our hands
so of course eleven doesn't want to
allow a 4 this would cement the past be
three pawn in there so Queen capture son
be three a four pushing the Queen back
Queen to c2 and the now comes a five
just strengthening the center and it
will be somewhat harder for white to
develop with Bishop to g2 by eleven and
now Knight to f6
we have castles and Bishop to e7 Magnus
also prepares the castle look the b1
making it harder for Magnus to develop
the light square bishop since the b7
point is under attack and the magnums
just castles and rook the b5 now putting
pressure on the e5 pawn here we have
Knight B to d7 now adding another
defender to the e5 pawn also perhaps
making room for f5 and the knight wants
to come to c5 when the night comes to c5
it will also cut off the rooks attack to
the e5 pawn Bishop to b2 level now wants
to get this rook over to be one to
double up rooks and then maybe or maybe
retreat this disappear in the develop it
to a different square later Knight the
c5 now going after the be three square
so here Magnus wants to get this night
over to a5 and then put a night on b3
which will be an excellent square for
the knight we have looked a be 111 our
doubles up on the B file and now Queen
to c7 developing the Queen adding
another defender here we have Bishop
back to c1 now the rooks are nicely
doubled on the B file in the Knights the
a5 now Magnus is already to put in item
b3
we have rook 5 back to be 211 doesn't
want to have his rooks disconnected when
the knight finally comes to b3 Bishop to
d7 now transferring the bishop over to
this diagonal to control Evans lies for
Bishop but the Knights are nicely
covering b7 so you don't have to worry
about the rooks we have Queen tadi one
now and here comes Bishop to c6 so black
has a very
development and it's very hard for
whites to figure out how he wants to
start developing we have night the e1
now offering a trade of light square
Bishop Bishop captures with rook King
captures and now Knight C finally comes
to b3
we have night the c2 and now comes just
be five by Magnus this is the way he
will introduce the the last inactive
piece into the game b5 he temporarily
sacrifices upon but now the the rook who
goes to be eight and when the row
captures this all of the pieces will be
nicely developed we at night capture Sun
b3 now a capture Sun b3 with this Magnus
created a very strong past beep on we
have nights to be forgetting the night
out of harm's way and do not rope
capture Sun b5 and here 11 has to decide
what to do he can't really do anything
with the ropes the point here is really
just a you know bone in Levin's throat
and it's hard to find a way to develop
you you don't really have a good square
for your bishop so here 11 decides to
sacrifice upon with E for allowing the D
captors and III I'm pass on to get some
activity for the Queen
so Magnus captures at end before
recapturing first Queen to f3 putting
pressure on the rock on a8 Magnus goes
roof to d8 now puts pressure on the d3
pawn and now just Bishop captures on e3
we have Queen to d7 by Magnus now
preparing to push f5 bring the Queen
over to e6 and also can start pushing in
the center we have looked to see one now
it's now 11 is able to activate the
ropes this rock is coming to be 1 maybe
he can use the open C file for his rooks
f5 by Magnus and rook beat the b1 now we
have Queen t6 supporting the advance of
this pawn to e4 and now Bishop to e2
adding another defender to the night
here but now 11 basically invites Magnus
to push efore since now you cannot
capture the bishop on d2 would be
hanging so Queen to b3 now not allowing
captures because Carlsen screen would be
hanging on e6 but this should capture
Sun before we have the shot capture Sun
before and now rook captures on d3
grabbing that very important
pawn and here Queen to a 7-eleven now
puts more pressure on the knight on a
five and Magnus goes Knight to c4 and
here 11 what 11 needs to do here is
Queen to a a to check once the King
moves
now repeat Queen a 7 check and the hope
hope that Magnus is happy with a draw
because if he's not if he was looked at
least 7 then 11 has Queen to a 4 which
comes with a double attack under Rokinon
the pawn and after the rook moves now
you eliminates the past b3 pawn and now
white is back in the game however here
11 once the go Queen a 8 check followed
by Queen to f8 check because the Queen
is the bishop also covers the f8 square
first he wants the get rid of call since
Queen from such an active square he
gives up the exchange rook captures on
c4 with Queen captures on c4 by Magnus
and now comes the Queen to aah check
King the f7 and Queen to f8 with check
came to g6 and now we reach the position
from the thumbnail if Quinta eh check
then Magnus can retreat with Queen to f7
so here 11 gives up a whole rook with
rook the c1 now you have to capture it
if you don't capture it it's it's a
forced draw because if you go back
Queeny 6th
preventive rook c6 then you get rook c7
threatening Queen captures and g7 and
after you block this with something like
rook to d7 now you just go back Queen to
c8 prevent captures because you lose the
Queen so you have to go back rugby 6 now
again offer a queen trade but now you
just go back Queen to f8 again put
pressure here and now we would see a
repetition here so after Luke to see one
magnet decides to grab the rope we have
rook Queen captures on c1 and now Queen
th check with King to h6 and the now
comes Queen to e6 check and you're
playing Magnus here you have this
position on the board feel free to pause
the video and try to find the best
continuation for black in this position
while I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who are able to do it
congratulations and continuing to play a
brilliant game the correct move is king
to h5 for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show because now
after Queen to f7 check you have g6 and
if Queen captures on h7 you successfully
defend with Queen to h6 so all of all
the tricks are gone and now you just
have two rooks for a bishop it's you
know pretty decisive advantage however
after Queen to e6 check
Magnus played the g6 miscalculating
something but now I don't even have to
tell you how to continue the game with
black without even pausing the video you
can calculate it all the way of course
now this diagonal has opened up and this
means trouble for Magnus so push up the
f8 check by Levin was played and now
King to h5 okay if King to g5 this is
probably what Magnus miscalculated then
of course you have Queen to e7 with
check and the ones the Queen reaches age
4 it's it's all over however Magnus
played King to h5 but 11 still goes
Queen to e7 and believe it or not it was
in this position on rule 41 that Magnus
calls and resigned the game because
there is no defense against both Queen
to h4 mate and also Queen captures on h7
King g4 and h3 mate so whatever you do
here let's say block with the Queen it
just captures King moves and h3 is made
and if you don't do it if you play
something like g5 to the pro and Queen
h4 then you just capture on h7 and it's
the same mate and if you try something
like rookie actress and g3 white it
doesn't care just H captures and g3 and
you don't have a useful move again the
the threats are the same either mate or
captures followed by a different mate so
there's a there is no way to do it even
Queen to g5 here now ok there is no H
pawn so you cannot meet with the h1 but
you still have Queen captures on h7 with
check a king to g4 and now the Queen can
come to h3 also to deliver mate which
was also possible in the previous line
but I just thought h3 was cooler so now
after Queen to e7 Magnus Carlsen
resigned to the game and 11 gets his
victory in the rapid section now I don't
know if I will be able to show more
games from this competition as there
were a lot more interesting games so
just in case I will tell you now the
results of the
of this battle for third place magnus
carlsen is the winner and he won third
place in the in this match even though I
believe in the rapid section both of
them got one win and in the boot section
again both of them got one win and two
games were drawn so in the end
Magnus warned by a margin of six points
which he earned by winning a game in the
classical time section so that's it from
the London chess classic the
Grantchester finals it's dinner and
taking first place then Maxime
holographs second Magnus Carlsen third
and 11 arena in fourth place so even
though that's all great I've seen an
interview with the ding-ding said that
he will not be playing any big
tournaments until the candidates
tournament in April so thing is now
going to be fully prepared for the
candidates and then we can just expect a
monster there so the candidates
tournament is going to be awesome
and yeah that's pretty much all I wanted
to mention do check out the info in the
description below like I mentioned like
I said if you if you you know run into
hit karo
which I'm happy birthday and that's
that's it for this game I do hope you
enjoyed it so I would like to thank
Steffen at Rocco's a Tony MOBOT guitar
and David Hillier for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
perhaps with with a game or two from the
Grantchester finals we'll see how it
goes
continue to check up on your wonderful
suggestions as there have been quite a
lot during the coverage of the
Grantchester
and of course after all is said and done
we are continuing with our next big saga
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day